όχι τώρα πουηνάμως και έχει πί σταψηλάσταα λόγια είπουν πότους τραγσιους βέβαια από την εποχή
που και γι αυτά τον λόγο είμαι από αυτούς τους οπαδού στου άρι που όταν
φτάσουμε τους βαθμός που μας επιτρέπουν να παραμείνουμε στην κατηγορία διάα έτσι συνηθισμένοι για θέτετη
ηθισμένι λέμε οραί παιθκέ χρειαζόύμαστε τώρα γλητώσαμε τη διαβάθμηση α έτσι είμαστε ευχαριστημένοι άλλ θέλουν
να πάμε να κερδήσουμε ακόμε και το γουέφα για το νομετουθε για τρέ κλίνοντας ιο
μήνημα στέλνει μικόλαζάμπογλου ένας για τρώς ένας επιστήμο νας ένας καθαξιωμένος θρωπος στον τομέα του
στου στον κόσμο που βλέπει αυτό το πότας και ίσως να έχει διαγνωθεί μαι καρκίνο
ίσως να φοβάται όλο αυτό πιο μήνυμαστέλνετο πρώτον είναι η πρόληψη γιατί η έγκαιρι διάγνωση
είναι αυτό πουσό η ζωές το γνωρίζουμεόλι το δευτρό να ακοψει τον σιγάρο όπως δήποτε
να κόει το σιγάρο και το τρίτον να μην αφησει τα όπλα να μην καταθέσει
τα όπλα και να γωνιστεί γιατί έχει δυνατότητης και ίασης και βελτίωση της ζωής του
και επιμήγηση της επιβίωσης λπομένος είναι θετικά τα μηνήματα και ευκομηγεία και ί στη αίμαστε
χαριστό πολύ για όλα αμοιραστεί κάτε για όλα όσα μας είπατε γιατί σας είπακεπριν κάποιοι
έχουν δεν μονοοποιρήσει όλο αυτό υπάρχει ένας φόβος γύρω από το όνομακαρκίατέχεται δήγιο θα περάσει
και αυτό υχαριστούμε πάρα πολλύγιαταστε καλά χαιλές και φίλι άλλο άντ έναλά ευτφοτκά ευτάσει το
τέλος του τα λέμε την ερχόμενε ευδομάλο